all right
maria yeah maria where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
um boyle heights so easter egg
boyle is a whole different ballgame okay
and uh tell me about your family you had
both your parents growing up
i don't have my father um but i have a
great mom
you know like every other mother you
know she
struggled to make anything
possible for her kids you know and
my father was a great father but
you know god took him so soon so i
didn't have a father
after the age of five you know
so you know i kind of grew up
in the hood in the barrio um
i learned the dope game and it was easy
to
from there just to get money from guys
something you matured fast yeah it was
way faster
you know because you told me your age i
have a hard time believing it
how old are you i don't want to say my
age
okay you told me a very young age i
don't want to say my age
is you know i understood um what uh
how would you describe your childhood
kind of rough
you know what i'm saying but it was easy
to fall into it on my end because
you know without a father figure trying
to you know
help you uh you know stay in the right
place
you know my mom taught me how
you know to do things a little different
so i liked it i'm not gonna sit here and
lie i
was so immune to that life it was
ridiculous like i'm even in it right now
still you know it's it's kind of hard to
detach yourself from something you got
so immune and
adapted to you know rolling with
certain age um
group that you know it's something that
was
not of a normal type of life you know
you left home at what age the age of
10 11. you know i'm saying where do you
go at 10 or 11
um i always be at my friends houses i
never stood at home
you know um i would come home when i
wanted to my mom
she would complain but what can she do
you know i was a
adolescent type of child you know always
wanting to do what i want to do and
that's how it's going to be
because she showed me that this is
okay you know so i ran around with it
and decided to do it on my own terms
and um you know went back home
and tried to make it you know work and
[Music]
there was times that you know i just
didn't like to bother with my family so
leave again um
you know it's easy to run the streets
nobody can tell you what to do
you do what you want to do and how you
want to do it
my life hasn't been so easy you know
but it's good right now for how i'm
already immune to you know
once you get a hold of how you're gonna
do what you want to do on the streets
nobody else can tell you anything where
do you live now you're in schedule
somewhat because i really do have a
place to go i choose not to because
i have a choice of drug and i have to
get
what i need to get how i need to get it
so by staying down here you're close to
your supply
yeah of course and what's your drug
crack cocaine now
you know and um i know if my kids are
watching this um
i apologize um
but it is what it is you know it's
reality
uh i do intend to stop
but just right now it's not the time you
know i'm still immune to this life
which uh what age were you when you
started using crack
at the age of 13.
and i'm not going to say no more of that
because i know you're trying to get my
age out of me
uh who uh who turned you on to crack at
13. i did
you take responsibility for it yes i do
you know i had a an abusive over age
boyfriend
at that time and um he still abused me a
lot like beat me
you know besides the abuse of sexual
that i had
younger but you know the trauma
and and the the messed up brain that i
had
you know i said you know i wonder what
what it feels to make him
do what he does but i didn't know it was
in time
of using the drug
that is how you develop it you know
because in the beginning it wasn't like
the way i am now
you know in the beginning you
everything's dandy you know i'm saying
everything goes so quick
um in your rougher parts of of the
of the roller coaster should i say
things are not always beautiful you know
i'm saying
there's people that may be in denial for
themselves but i'm not
i'm not ashamed because i know that i
probably have hurt
a lot of my you know real close loved
ones and
i didn't intend to it's just something
that happened with
the choices i've done and made you know
and sometimes i wish i could turn back
time and
do things a little different and
sometimes it just happens the way it
happens you know
and i know the ones that love you the
most are always gonna stick there
so i just have like less than a handful
of people that i can honestly say love
me and still
are are here with me regardless of my
addiction
regardless of what i've been through or
put them
they give me my space and they're
waiting for me to be ready on my term
and i i i respect that now you know
before i did it
because i didn't want to i thought they
were trying to just hold me back and not
you know oh my god control my life but i
understood that
you know when you're ready to change
it's going to be within self
not not nobody else's terms you know
and this street the streets are not not
no joke but i
i take them you know i take risks
um i have been raped
um abused
physically mentally sexually being out
here in these streets
you know and i still don't know how i
intend to still
smoke or do what i have to do i'm not
gonna say the other
but everybody should know you know i'm
saying ain't no
ain't nobody that has their right mind
not know what i'm speaking of
but as i'm saying it is a truth you know
you are grown you do things that you
have to do by any means necessary
to get what you need to get to be okay
or
numb for the moment you know what i'm
saying for whatever
situation you're going through or
however you have to handle it
you escape people say oh no you're
you're this and you're that it's not
that it's just because it's true
you might just have that trauma that
really beats you and
you have to numb yourself to get okay
for yourself you know a lot of people
don't understand that some
people's ways of doing things are not
the same as others
and a lot of people in life seem to
judge people instead of trying to
help us or be our support you know i'm
saying to help us get off
slowly or however we have to get off you
know
because it ain't easy for me i tried it
it didn't work i tried to do it for self
uh uh like twice and
another situation occurred and i ran
again
you know i'm a chronic user you've been
to rehabs and stuff like that yes i have
i haven't been to prison
i've been to jail so prison in jail gets
you clean yeah
for the moment don't get it twisted for
the time that you're in there yes
and you will say anything because that
there you feel
saying there you feel like you have to
be clean there's no way there's no other
choice there's
you could get high don't get me twisted
but you think you're gonna really want
to waste all your money on getting high
when you already know you gained a lot
of weight you're healthy and you're
thinking right
and you're controlled by the time that
you have to do everything
you're not like in this free world it's
not easy
you know what i'm saying because us
chronic users
that know that we run
from the drama or the or the hurt or the
pain that we go through
or whatever you know and we don't want
to feel
we're gonna go and run to where we're
comfortable and it's easy
because when you go to your stomping
grounds where you know it's easy to get
it like this without even having money
it's more easier to just numb it and go
and
and just get on the roller coaster and
not get off you know like no let me keep
on going
let everybody else you know get on with
me
and that's how it feels literally it
does
because there's going to be times where
you're going to go up you're going to go
down and you're going to take that
circle you know
and it's some people don't like to admit
it
i have integrity i'm accepting
everything i go through you take
responsibility
yeah i do that's great that's rare you
know what i'm saying because
there's no nobody's making me i ran to
it i'm the one that went to it
nobody else did it for me your mom was
an addict right
um at one point yes she stopped after
a certain amount of time and she tried
to you know show me but i told her you
still can't show me
because i have to be able to say okay
i have to be the one good with it i have
to be the one
to know that it's me the reason why i'm
stopping because i can't do it for you i
can't do it for my grandma i can't do it
for
none of my you know my babies and i
can't do it for
my significant other if i would have one
but right now i'm doing it
because i have went through a lot of
trauma and there's
right now i'm like facing and i have to
go
you know to court on um a rape charge
that somebody did to me you know and i
i get fear i fear you know
who of his family may be at that at that
courtroom
or you know what i'm saying will they
have something to
do something to me or to my family or
do do they know that they know where i
stay or
that's why i do all this because i'm
scared i'm nervous i don't know
if he doesn't does know people or he
doesn't
he might be the one in jail but how do i
know his people are incapable of doing
something for having him
go in there you know there's people that
it's crazy in this world
and you know i'll test the water but
you know i don't know if it's gonna be
my last where my kids won't be able to
see me anymore you know
so that's why you think that's why a lot
of women don't
yeah don't say anything because there's
repercussions if you do
yeah and um
there's sometimes not just from the
police if you're a sex worker but no
like on the street i'm gonna tell you it
is scary in the street
you know what i'm saying when a person
either
sticks a knife to your to your head or a
gun
you know and they're raping you you you
know you don't even know if it's the
last moment you're gonna live you know
and it is scary it's something powerful
that you just don't understand you know
and um it's something in life that's
kind of
you know you have to just either take
the risk or go and hide you know
and numb yourself so you know that
you're safe and you're okay
so you know it's is that that's the type
of things that people don't understand
what's the hurt and the things that we
do in the streets you know straight up
they don't but even though that has
happened to me
it's made me a stronger woman and
understand that taking responsibility is
something
that's okay it's okay to surrender and
know that it's
you know not nothing bad who cares if
the next person talks about you
they they're really not doing nothing
for you or your habit
you know is living this lifestyle made
you
you made you stronger it has but it has
made me think too like i do want to stop
i'm just
i don't know when is the time but some
people tell me when i try to give
advice from other people they tell me
you don't know
you know the moment because you'll leave
when the moment you leave you know
you're done
so i guess then i will know but right
now i'm still not ready
you know straight up when i'm not do you
have family members and things like that
trying to get you to quit
they just said when you're ready now now
they know so they don't try to pressure
me or
get me to go home because they know that
if they do that i run
and they don't want to do that they just
want me to come by myself so they say
when you're ready you know your
your house is here come whenever you
want
yeah one of the best things i've heard
from somebody who works at a rehab said
uh
when an addict addict's ready to quit no
one can stop them
but when an addict isn't ready to quit
no one can make them
i know and they can't because even my
mom
she i have her phone cause
a couple of days back um i got drugged
and raped
and um they stole my other phone my mom
bought me
just to keep in contact with me
i don't know why the people did it i
didn't know them
and you know i thought i was safe with
them little do you know your own race
can do so much damage to you
and people are talking about criticism
of other races like blacks and whites
and
asians or whatever but your own kind can
get you to
you know and it was a heroin addict that
did that to me
and a female at that she set me up with
her own friends
so i can get raped it's kind of scary
thing you know you
you think that you have somebody you can
trust
and that person betrays you she gave me
the date
break drug in a liquid form and a
cigarette
and i didn't know and
when i woke up i knew it was
something weird because i didn't wake up
with any shoes
my bag my phones everything was gone
but i had bad aches on my body
they raped me had my they even had the
nerve to put my
pants back exactly the way they were but
i didn't have shoes on
but probably my body was hurting because
i was fighting back without knowing
you know consciously but i was gone my
mind
didn't allow me to see or feel you know
and
the weirdest thing that i know god serve
like god
exists should i say because i woke up at
a church
like the back steps of a church
and i didn't know you know and i always
say that god has
no matter what he's he's kept me alive
so i know that i'm not meant to die yet
but i still don't want to live all my
life
until i get like you know the day that i
die it's the last day i'm going to get i
know i do want to have a better life i
do want to get out of
downtown i do want to get
my children back you know and i want my
life back older kids
all right again we want i don't want to
say that
do you like your kids right now no
because the oldest one she's kind of
upset at me but it's okay
she has every right to right now you
know she doesn't understand
but she will one day she will she will
one day because that day
that she gets to understand or she even
gets to see this
she'll understand that her mom wasn't
okay up here
and neither here you know herself
but she tried the best she could is that
what you think most
people that don't use drugs perhaps
maybe they don't understand about
yeah they don't you know what i'm saying
myself i made a decision to try drugs
no it's just something that someone was
beating me
and i he would only beat me on this drug
but i didn't know he was using that drug
to after
when my mother said something about it
and i said well
wow that's the reason
i'm gonna try it so i found a way to get
it
which it wasn't hard i did it
and it was over you know but my
my mom did and i was using until like
later on you know
and um but it also numbs the pain of
what happened in your childhood
yeah you know a family member of mine
you know i was only five years old after
you know my father had died
that that person started um abusing me
without any of my family believing me
and seven years i killed my mom [ __ ]
seven years and there's times i don't
remember anything he did to me but i
remember the beginning but never the end
just remember walking out the room and
it bothers me because
i always want to remember and it's
it beats me up inside because i can't
remember
you know it's kind of hard it's like
looking for something and
you're trying to find it and you think
you're gonna locate it and you can't
because there's like a big gap
that will not allow you to get to where
you need you know
need to get to you know and it's kind of
like
you try this way and that way and you
try to view it and see it
no there's no way because your mind
blocks it
yeah i guess the only way that they
can't find out is like they say the
hypnosis or whatever
but i don't even want to know that
because that probably
that pain that he made me suffer
i don't want to you know but it all
started because of him
you know and i never had
the nerve to you know voice it and
sometimes i say that's why i'm this
screwed up you know
but i've i guess forgiving him now and
i just don't associate with him i don't
bother with him he's in my family still
i choose not to no more not even be
around his his kids or
or my aunt you know i just keep them
away
i say as far as as i can
i try not to cross paths at all with him
because he's damaged me a lot
and i couldn't even believe my aunt
never believed me
but it's okay i guess god there's a big
god in his
in his time he will do what he has to do
and go through you know
so it's okay life is cool
for right now but
i don't know whenever i'm ready
hopefully i'm not
like 70 when i'm long and ready to
change you know i hope it's sooner than
that
you know just for those that don't
understand
try to put yourself in a position where
you can't view it
you don't have to be in a person's shoes
but view it
from a different angle and a different
perspective and try to understand a
person's
hurt their um their damage
um mind or you know
try to support somebody that is in a
situation like mine
so you guys don't have to misjudge them
or
mislead them into something they don't
you know
don't know how to get out of as well
because that could be damaging too
when you're judging a person that that's
sick already
in their head and numbing themselves so
yeah you know life ain't ain't pretty
but we seem to control ourselves and
know ourselves in a different
in our own little world should we say so
i think it's good it's not nothing bad
it's just some people chose to live the
i went to college and and bachelors and
masters and all and that's okay too
you know and well i think i graduated
from the streets you know i'm saying
that's what i say
hey i got my bachelor's out here you
know
but because there is things in the
streets too if you don't know a certain
level
they treat you a little different so the
same way a normal
life is the same way as the streets so
only certain people can tell they've
been in our shoes
and i think that's it
all right maria thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you you're a great speaker
thank you you're welcome good luck
thank you
you